дума йому про не машину у себе у собі
ангелу меркель канцлер до них від шини про
тих хто особлива німецька політична
ось немає в будинку з-за кордоном однак
на спартину політичну динаміку між
парламентом і відомством канцлера з
це так широко вид будинку інший ревінь
федеральний президент йдуть конституцію я
головною людиною а ремонт і в ньому
дуже і
теж у чому сенсея посади роль
федерального президента ви носите на
порядок дані харчування та ким ожив і вас
ти хочеш їх причин складно порушу вати
та активним політикам президент ріхард
фон white зикру увійшов в історію до
висловивши німцям чорний мати пляшковим і
заправку нацистської не метшин і 8-ми
травня блудним викликало не
ви але звернула на свитку раніше не
людського націонал-соціалістичного
режиму
багатий про президента поважала за свій розум від
біля воріт і нас ручну правду у сієні
міченою травня прокотитися імпульс
пробудженням і моїм вузол і пошиті нашу
зону комфорту заповідь на хоч чикова
Нею іслам же зараз я часті але й не на
чини cool та вмовляння йому крайній варіант
ви просто не наших ризикових не матчі але
не з вини коза ти анніс принципу не
вони рефлекторно так за клікають що
негайно взята на себе більше
глобального вигляду і дальності гаук 5
штук ну в ньому ти ви знати ще bespeco але
і дальністю
попадуть у руку багата, вибір чергувати
його і багатих тоу чика з чого настає
буду вбитий на загальну силу за розходиться з
плюс такий розколот цієї мої досягли
шаль на захисті вкр з важливі взагалі бог.
то образливе найбільшою ви клік за 1 з
працюючих знову здасть нам і додайся
коли політично стабільність руїн вулиця
конституції на роль президента люди на
цементу я на тобі може стати важливо
великий їх будь коли годинник побільшало
не пивними
т порушується щоб політати та 100 поїхати
крем і сухим зараз тіло випливаючи взята
наприклад fd
а чим більше не пивним і ставити
обставлені ситуація в краї немає їм
важливі важе та зграя
роль президента жаху трампа фейкових
новим і популістських рук і вояки
набирають звернув по всій Європі новий
президент як java папороть буду взуття
сковороди таємниця багата більше
ніш просто представляти україну